good morning Hank it's Wednesday I woke
up in the yetis childhood bedroom around
7:00 brushed my teeth while
contemplating how disconcertingly often
I videotape myself brushing my teeth and
went downstairs to find Henry helpfully
removing trash from a trash can Willie
was like I want to try we had to drive
from Birmingham back to Indianapolis
that day so first I put this stuff in
this bag that I changed clothes
suspiciously similar pants are
suspiciously similar and then I started
packing the car tank there was a time
when in a pinch I could fit my whole
life into a small sedan now I have to
strap a car top carrier on to my station
wagon if I want to go on a five-day trip
remembering the Unbearable Lightness of
my younger and more vulnerable years
made me think about all the road trips
I'd gone on in the past I'd driven to
the Grand Canyon and Alaska and San
Francisco and Arthur Nebraska home of
the world's smallest courthouse in those
days I'd get distracted by all kinds of
roadside attractions but this trip was
all about speed I left over barbecue for
breakfast we didn't stop until lunch
Willie says I claimed this snow for
fireball Wilson Roberts Henry says
tables are for climbing I've been
feeling nostalgic but then I thought
about how when those old road trips I
couldn't order Happy Meals or play in
the play place which I can finally do
again after more than two decades back
in the car Willie slept and I read Sara
an excerpt from a German review of one
of my books as translated by Google the
bone mode density is high in these by
sections easily guessed Essen Gotham as
we kept driving north I thought about
how all my old road trips had taken me
West partly because that's where the
open space is in America and partly
because of this amazing line from a book
I loved called all the king's men for
West is where we all plan to go someday
Robert Penn Warren wrote it is where you
go when the land gives out in the
Oldfield Pines encroach it is where you
go when you get the letter saying flee
all is discovered it is where you go
when you look down at the blade in your
hand and the blood on it it is where you
go when you are told that you are a
bubble on the tide of empire a bubble on
the tide of empire Hank French the llama
what I wouldn't give to write sentences
like that anyway then we had to stop for
gas so we decided to let Henry Drive for
a while it must be said that despite
Henry's abundant charms he is not
terribly attentive behind the wheel we
kept driving I was still thinking about
the old road trips and this new one
about becoming a capital a adult with
capital our responsibilities
I remember when we
to the world's smallest courthouse in
Arthur Nebraska all those years ago
after 12 hours of driving I was struck
by the fact that it was not like
actually that small I mean frankly if I
were so inclined I could easily build a
much smaller courthouse in my basement
as we got back in the car to drive to
carhenge an exact replica of Stonehenge
made out of junked cars I complained to
a fellow traveler who reminded me that
it was not the destination that mattered
but the journey which is true in its way
but destinations aren't all bad Hank and
as we kept driving north the whole
family in the car together it got darker
and snowy
until finally the road delivered us to
the one place that all my youthful trips
west never could home Hank I'll see you
on Friday